all right
ready jc jay coolio
shall we are we rolling
yeah yeah i'm rolling on my end should
we be rolling
[Laughter]
it's time for a quarter hello everybody
welcome back to another wonderful
episode of the corridor cast episode 118
i believe man
we've been doing this
for years now at this point and i i'm
not convinced we've gotten any better at
it but that's okay because podcasting is
um you know just something we do for fun
um the point isn't to uh
make the next you know
[Music]
maybe we could get better at speaking
with each other but
let's say
listen sam i got a new
microphone
just recently after two years of doing
the corridor cast recently yeah yeah
using i'm no longer using a usb plug-in
microphone i've got a real it's like a
crash microphone here coming from it's
coming down it's coming from that that's
how you know you've made it i can't get
to the heavens and the microphone comes
down yeah yeah that's right welcome to
texas radio station
episode 118
fm
98.3
um but anyways uh we thought it'd be a
little fun to play a little uh spyfall
today because uh you know what
everyone's been working hard and spyfall
is a heck of a fun game to just kick
back with your buddies and
have a laugh hey jake why don't you tell
them what your first choice was this
evening
listen
we were like hey maybe we shouldn't play
spyfall so we tested out a different
game just to see you know if it was
before
oh scrabble
thank you for like proposing ideas like
this is good i was excited for scrabble
i was like
if you want to see us play scrabble on
the corridor cast we can do that just
let us know in the comments i really
want to play boulder
with like two other people though we
need to get like two other people on the
couch
and then yeah
play some boulder dash next time okay
like
i don't know we'd have to cut out all
the the thinking moments though but
yeah so you because it's a lot of just
sitting and writing
you have like a one person one person is
just a narrator and then during the
thinking and writing moments they they
go to each person and they give their
perspective as the narrator like what
that person is doing interview them
yeah podcast pictionary oh my god just
people yelling random stuff
no you're
[Laughter]
hey guys welcome to the next episode of
podcast pictionary if you could figure
out what's going on
you could figure out what's being drawn
before we guess it it's infuriating
so yeah we got a new spy fall we're
using that spyfall app today because yes
sir our tanner crewson one is broken
one spy fall two
we have adults only
locations and then outrageous locations
outrageous let's let do you want to
start with outrageous
maybe do you want to go straight to
adults only adultery was fine
let's let's just we're adults here let's
just play one regular game okay
and warmer yeah and a warm-up then we
can see the outrageous locations and
then all right the adults-only locations
we'll
we'll see
all right
see you guys on the beach
see you guys on the nude boots let's do
it
[Laughter]
this location is the spa well that's for
adults only
all righty well i got my location
and who goes first
it doesn't say
on this app it doesn't think about why
don't you go first sam
[Music]
all right i'll go first
hey nick since you're here hey man i
figured i'd ask you a little uh
question about this location see if you
can fill me in as to whether you are a
spy or not whether you know the true
nature of this location
the classic question let's see so my
question is
as to not reveal the location except to
those who know what it is already um
hmm
this one gives you question hints at the
bottom no you can't think of a question
this is more of
oh
is this more uh is this a a thing
um
okay two consoles all right i'm gonna
give you two video game consoles okay
is this
the nintendo
wii
or is the xbox 360.
um
i'm gonna go with nintendo wii nintendo
yeah we all right
yes sir sounds good
got it
wow all right
nintendo wii so i suppose it's my turn
to ask a question right it's your turn
all right jordan hi
what's what's uh
what's like a item that isn't a
a piece of fashion that one might want
to bring with them to this location
i'd probably want to bring like a
headband
headband
headband interesting
is that thanks for your answer all right
thank you you're very welcome
thank you for your question nick you're
welcome uh
hi jake
hmm
hi jordan hi uh
how's it going
oh
my god i'm so good um
if
there were to be a legal activity at
this location
what might be like the first
type of illegal activity
i know
it's not good
criminal criminal activity of course
that's right criminal activity
yes okay
to the question illegal activity is
criminal activity criminal
activity same
is the question the answer is the same
as the question but with different words
it's essentially the same no no it
counts
you pass there you go all right great
you're generic hey uh for now wait has
samban asked a question yet no no no sam
slap
hey um
uh
wha what would you do
what would you do
if you had to park a car
at this location
i would take my car and drive it to the
parking lot
and then i would get out and that would
be it
that's it okay
all right that's all jordan
yeah
since
didn't get a lot out of that last
exchange there maybe i'll throw you a
question here um
um
would this be like a
muddy
s a place
uh or a place with a lot of rocks
or a place
with a lot of water
you know what's crazy about that
question sam what that's crazy
is essentially depending on
the type of
location
type of location
bear with me here um you could find all
of these things there okay you really
could yeah now
might i choose my preference
if you wish or but i think your answer
is sufficient
perfect
and jake are you lost
you alright no why don't you choose your
why don't you choose your preference i'd
like to hear this because you feel real
i feel like you feel real confident that
you're about to call me the spy right
now and i just that's gonna be a damn
shame for everybody because yeah if you
don't give jake any more clues
then everyone's gonna lose then
everyone's gone
it's okay it's okay it's okay we got
this we're good no my answer was great
yeah it was it was excellent well then
why don't you ask sam a question because
he seems real confident about who he is
i can't throw it back though
no backsies no
backsies oh you did throw it back all
right well fine
you got me or nick that's the best
you're gonna get
i feel like i should go ahead and go
back to you
sorry nick you oh by all means jordan
yeah
um
[Laughter]
so dark
[Laughter]
classic moment
classic moments in history
how many classic moments in spyfall
history how much would you
maybe spend here hmm
getting down to numbers
let's let's get the numbers let's crunch
the numbers
we've crunched the numbers and
it's a lot
it's a lot
that's it
it is absurd
well we got two minutes so uh let's keep
him going there jake
go ahead
wait just now that was that was the
question
oh i thought jordan was asking nick a
question i'm sorry no how much would how
much would you spend here
yeah like oh oh you want a serious
answer yeah uh
a lot
yeah that's my answer
yes
i like the commitment dude i like the
comments a lot
yeah yep kind of go all out
i really go all out when i play this
game i mean that's one of the things
you're gonna find out about me is
i go
hard
you're gonna you're about to find this
up
you're about to find this out about me
okay you might not know it
yet so uh
yeah so jake uh
we're all okay all right sam um
okay
give me the most likely outcome uh if
you were to rob this place
uh well you'd walk away with some cash
and uh
that's it
yeah you'd get some
cash
maybe some clothes
[Music]
maybe a boat
depending i think you're
i think
you're just saying all those things
because you think i'm the spy
you're just trying honestly i think you
could come away with the crown jewels
if you rob this place
just i'm just messing around that's a
joke
all right
it's not the callous we have 25 seconds
all right hey nick um yo
last question
all right yo yeah
gives me straight man all right
is this place chill
or is it
natural
let's just say i would not want to turn
up here all right i don't this is a
place where i want to kick off my shoes
and ch you don't want to get turnt no i
want to chill all right there we go
and that's the end of the round yep all
right shall we i'll vote yeah that's
jake yes jake hi joshua uh well that's
fine and i am the spy but you know what
i know where everyone is okay
yes tell us
you're at the police station
it's not chill
mud water
thank you for the best played round of
spyfall ever if we can all quit now
no no no no this was your warm-up
right now
that was a warm-up it was a warm-up i
was in the hot seat i didn't get it
right off the what was the whole
question about seat you mean are you
like like in a sauna
no what was the question about the
nintendo wii
oh there's a point
in korea
it's like one of the biggest spas in l.a
yep these questions were so good i could
not pick up on anything more like fancy
than xbox oh interesting well there's
multiple multiple answers but yeah clint
always talks about we still so yeah
where there's modern stones
have you ever been to alcatraz son like
you go to like a
hut or like a it's like a bamboo fence
around you yeah rescue
status listen listen that was my warm-up
god damn it let's move on let's let's
get it all right let's move on we're
moving on do you want to move on to a
new new
reduced spyfall number two see with the
new set of locations
because we're working our way to
outrageous locations
do your worst sam absolutely outrageous
i was just memorizing this round of
locations
this location is so random
hey everybody i am here at the north
pole to take a quick break to tell you
about today's sponsor quip because santa
has some of the best teeth i've ever
seen and he's told me that good health
starts with good habits i mean look this
guy has been around for centuries okay
and you know yeah he might have a little
extra you know chunk on him but that's
just to keep him warm because it's so
dang cold up here so anyways let me tell
you about today's sponsor quip and how
they can give you good health from good
habits the quip electric toothbrush is
their signature product loved by over
seven million people because it has
timed sonic vibrations with 30 second
pulses that guide you to a perfect
dentist recommended two-minute clean it
has a lightweight sleek design that's
perfect for kids and adults with no
dangling wires or bulky chargers to log
along with you it has a multi-use travel
cover which makes it easy to pack and go
and also doubles as a mirror mount so
you have less clutter in your bag and
also equipped toothbrushes come with
reusable handles in a range of sleek
metal hues including the best-selling
all black and the best part about
starting your oral care journey with
quip is that they can go above and
beyond brushing you can upgrade your
quip with a new smart motor to track and
improve your brushing with a free quip
app and earn amazing rewards like free
refills products target gift cards and
more just for tracking your brushing
santa probably didn't think of that and
even more importantly beyond the brush
quip has everything you need to build a
complete health routine they have
anti-cavity toothpaste floss string
reusable floss picks refillable gum and
refillable mouthwash to help you get the
best oral care you can get on the planet
quip also delivers fresh floss
toothpaste mouthwash and gum refills
every three months from five dollars and
up and the shipping is free of course so
you can save money there and avoid the
hustle and bustle from trying to go into
a store during the holidays trust me
they're busier than santa's workshop
with affordable and stylish brushes you
can get started on your healthcare
journey right away for just 25
you're not gonna be paying through the
teeth just to get your brush
i know paying through the teeth get it i
know look santa made me say that one
sorry so if you're interested in getting
started on all of this today or maybe
you want to get it for a loved one or a
friend head on over to get quip dot com
slash quarter cast and you will get your
first refill for free that's g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash quarter cast where
you're gonna get your first refill for
free quip the good habits company that's
it for me up here at the north pole i
gotta get back to the podcast but maybe
next time we'll have santa and his
reindeer here in the studio until then
well i'm gonna see you in like a second
so i'll see you back in the podcast all
right
this location is the cemetery
all right we got a new location so
random remember your um nick characters
too yeah i got a character all right
i gotta catch oh yeah i forget about
that all right
well you didn't have one last round so
sam sam yeah
nick we're in a new location in a new
whole set of locations and i know what
it is
good well i i just
just to kind of start broad here and
start narrowing ourselves down is this a
place where it would be socially
acceptable to make a really loud noise
like a fart no like verbally or or a
fart like just a verbal loud noise
yeah yeah
honestly it depends on
the the time of day and the
crowd you're trying to impress
okay
thank you that's uh well that's
a good idea that's interesting
wow
okay
all right
jake
yeah this is your redemption story okay
welcome to the story
of my redemption
all right all right all right
what is a good
sport
that would be played at this location
when i come to this location uh
the my favorite sport to play is
sports ball
sports ball
yeah
sports ball
gotcha love it cause you never know you
never know what can happen
in a good game of sports ball you never
know how that game is going to turn out
that's like answering my favorite colors
the rainbow
no
actually
this
happens to have a deeper meaning than it
appears to have is that inside joke a
little bit maybe if you
knew
yeah i know maybe if you've ever played
maybe if you were you'd realize this is
the fifth
location for it never played
all right
um
uh uh jordan that's a deep cut by the
way
jordan um
would you say that the people who
work here
are in uniform
yeah
you want to be able to tell who's who
considering the location
what was that
sorry cut out a little bit you want to
be able to tell who's who considering
the location
you can get a little
fair look gold order
[Laughter]
how am i now
i'm feeling
like
i'm ready to make some money
what
look i mean there's always room
there's always room for profit i don't
have the character there's always room
for profit how dare you
[Laughter]
deep
nick's going deep he doesn't care
all right um
let's see here
i'm a little confused right now so
i'm a little i'm a little confused as to
what's happening here
let me think let me think why don't you
ask sam a question nick so let's get
started let's vet out some of that
confusion is this so just tell me which
movie
comes more to mind okay from this
location okay you're getting a selection
yes a selection okay d um
rather which genre here okay so we're
first of all
fast-paced casino heist or slash robbery
film all right
yeah kind like
ocean's eleven five but it could be like
you know anything could be heist okay
all right could be ocean's 12 13.
not that like hardcore action flick 80s
style okay like you know there's
multiple locations that could be there c
horror film or something to do with the
occult
yeah c c okay
great
the occult
the
the only
the only occult
that lives
my organization
uh i'm a little confused right now
that's how we like it everyone why don't
you ask some questions sam and let's get
this party started
uh
jordan
yes
um
[Laughter]
how about this how about this how about
this
um
yeah is this the type of place
where you want to live
right next to it
or
would you prefer
to have it be a little further away i
want it far away okay
far far away take me far away from here
i don't like this place all right all
right jordan's really in character right
now i appreciate that yeah i do too
thank you
your innocence is quite clear
and i'm growing further confused
unless jake's redemption story is
secretly a spy story
redemption
[Music]
jake
come on jordan
if there was to be entertainment here
what kind of entertainment would there
be
well some call what we do here
entertainment
but to me
it's more than that
what
wait a minute
okay wait a minute what does that mean
[Laughter]
so nick
look at me look at me
i'm asking the questions now i'm the
captain now
nick uh
[Music]
is there anything we can do about that
plague down uh
down in the uh flea district
is there anything we can do about the
plague
down in the flea district yeah
that's my question look man
here we don't really worry about what we
do with plagues okay we
we just
try to pick up the pieces and move on
okay mm-hmm
yeah
okay
all right
thanks for asking
hey
hey i wish i could ask a question right
back to you you're welcome you're
welcome
so i'll ask i'll ask sam here i
understand why everyone's confused is
anyone else confused
like
not about the location of course no of
course not but i don't know
about who's the spy
maybe
who
who oh and the round's over
that's our time sad jordan keep going
are you one of the hardest vias sad
jordan
sad jordan is definitely wondering who
the spy is
i think it's sam not gonna lie jordan
played it well
nick
your answers were
they're fine
i don't know man that that plague
question really got me like
oh come on
it's simple this is a simple some call
what we do entertainment some say it's
more
is that from a movie
i think it's jake i think it's jake
again dude jake's redemption story
again it is it is me but guess what
my redemption story comes true because
y'all are at the cemetery oh yeah
you totally got it you put us in our
graves you put us in our graves jake
yeah nice man
what gave it away i said it was one of
you guys uh at first i thought it was
the at first i thought it was the u.n
which is why i asked that uniform
question
but i was like i've actually never seen
a uniform at this point
but then yeah nick you you asked
something about like which seemed very
like existential and abstract i can't
remember what it was
you asked some question about like what
does it all mean or something no i asked
about the movies and then you you asked
me and i answered we just pick up the
pieces so maybe that's what that that's
what finally gave it away for me
at the graveyard though so i'm a
capitalist who profits off off misery
that was my job
that's what made me think yeah your
answer to the one before that made me
think it was the u.n
i was like okay it's either the u.n or
the kitten's good boy i know i got to
talk like my role
yeah i know jordan's the only one like
really talking to her these bodies don't
bury themselves those bodies don't bury
themselves were you a grieving uh a
grieving family member
the sports ball
so the sports ball i i think i might get
it now but sportsball son of a dungeon
that was the yeah
and son of a dungeon all the sports ball
fields are also graveyards at the same
time
because i was just lucky then my answer
to that was just lucky
you know what's really funny i asked
that question not even thinking about
that i was like i was trying to throw
you a curveball yeah you were like
and then he said sportsbone like oh damn
that is like perfect yeah that is
a perfect answer so good because like
half the people literally didn't
understand your answer but sam was like
convinced
no wonder you were confused i was that's
why i was confused because that was like
too perfect
episode oh yeah literally sports balls
played in graveyards death in sports
it is
in son of a dungeon sportsmail is played
on a graveyard
well they just yeah you play the ball
game and then you die and they put you
in the ground right there and you keep
playing
and then the game continues yeah
yeah if you die in sports ball yeah
right there right in the field right
then and there
they wait until the game is over to bury
you but still
it becomes a sports game and then it
turns into a funeral funeral yeah
funerals always follow the match
all right let's see if let's see if i
can get spy three times in a row all
right yeah
shall we do adults only or outrageous
outrageous let's start there and then
outrageous yeah
is it more outrageous than adults only
let's find out uh i think yeah well we
did we've done adults only and it wasn't
that outrageous no it wasn't
i expected it to be more outrageous it
wasn't all right we got some outrageous
locations
shark cage nobody's there
here we go
get ready
this location is the tv cooking show
uh
you jordan jake who wants to kick it off
hugo jake i'll kick it off sure
um all right
so
um
would you say that the average age of
people who generally work at this
location is
under 40 or
over
40. who are you asking
oh good question i'm asking you sam oh
i would have to say probably over 40.
really
yeah the average working age
okay
but you're gonna hire miners
what's that
going to hire miners
well about 20 children
you want people with experience yeah
real true life experience
because that's what you need here that's
what you need here that's exactly this
location you need all right all right at
this point i'm
satisfied for now
for now i'll be i'll be back for more
later put a pin in it to get my pound of
flesh from you spy
and heat it already let's talk about
life experiences okay
let's do it
in the realm of life experiences how
many people
would generally get to have a life
experience here
we talking
many many most of us on
very few
i mean i guess it do do you actually
mean like
experiencing it for all it is
okay well i'd say it's a very it's a
very few amount a chosen few let's just
say that okay yeah
i mean
yeah i'll i'll leave it there it's a
chosen few shows chosen
so
huh
jordan yeah
generally
would you expect there to be
unpleasant smells
or pleasant smells in this location
you know it all really depends on
of the person but normally
it should smell good here should
definitely smell good
definitely definitely depending on the
person though but it should definitely
most likely smell good cool
great
all right yep thanks you're welcome
uh i'm
satisfied with that answer
thank you
let's see oh
where
family
where would we
be doing the activities at this location
where
are you asking me what the location is
hey
sham where are we
[Laughter]
where would this location be
where would like is this so
the sub location there we are
uh
i mean
i mean i think oh that's a tough one to
answer you're gonna give it away we
think yeah
[Applause]
yeah maybe there could be one
right down the street
yes
that was beautiful you never know
yeah right right down the street huh
yeah right you never know you never know
logic dictates
yeah
as they say yep
three minutes left
all right uh jake
yeah maybe i can restore some hope
oh y'all think it's me again
what no no no no no i'm speaking for
myself
okay
you can restore some hope in me oh okay
all right i'd love to do that let me
give you just give me the chance you
give me that chance
is this
the type of place
let's talk about senses all right
is this the type of place you experience
with your hands
your eyes or your ears
good question
well um for me personally
has a lot to do with the hands and the
eyes
but for others
the ears
it's the warehouse rave
no it's not survival
[Applause]
i got my suspicion son
all right
it's insane cooking the tv cooking show
that's why when you said up the street i
was like well we're in l.a there's
studios
because there's warehouses all around i
mean
people fell around here all the time
right it's interesting that you thought
it was the warehouse rave because they
used to throw warehouse raves in our
studio yeah
and in other studios like it where they
now probably film tv cooking shows and
then you said ear well you said the
seventh the age thing and everyone gave
me the weird look of like over 40
like and it's like
cooking shows we talk about tons of
people over 40 are working on that stuff
yeah
well i just didn't want to give it away
you should have said like
30 but yeah so anyways honestly
came down to that and then when you said
hands and eyes i was thinking you're the
dj and everyone else is using their ears
i was like dude some people gotta walk
no i was the cameraman
oh okay i was the director
but like obviously exactly an audio guy
you know
i had to go for it no you know what you
should you no that was good i like your
technique
and i honestly thought it was either you
or nick and i wasn't sure
all right well
there it is all right there it is that
was enough here we go here we go
whoa
all right are we
ready to go
let's take to
[Laughter]
adults only locations
[Music]
to put them to bed
your babies to bed hide your kids hide
your wife and cover your ears
go to the website
let's do it all right let's see
what adults only has in store
sex dungeon yeah
just all dungeons
yeah
uh oh same location not that bad at all
all right here we go
these are normal
you want to do it one more time yeah
let's get a funnier one
you want to try again all right we can
try again let's do it okay i know
whoever the spy was i'm just going to
tell you right now we got the locker
room yeah yeah i think we can get
something a little zestier than that
adults only locked down what are you
talking about locker rooms in middle
schools
i was in a lot of crazy i was in the
locker room when i was 11. yeah
i don't know what's going on
all right locker room again
let's go
this location is the private jet
all right yes i'm in character adults
only
this is so strong
jordan i think
you got to kick us off
oh i'm going to kick it i'm going
okay
um
[Music]
here i am
in the location yes you're at the same
location as me yes uh what would you
probably be eating
oh well whatever's
observed
well
i don't know what they have today but
i'll eat it it's probably good
since i'm an adult and i eat adult food
are you in character and this is an
adult
you're in character well actually now
that i read my role
since i'm not a spy
i uh i'm going to say the character
sounds like this now
either way
nicholas yes
all right okay
um
[Music]
tell me one way you're satisfied with
that answer
tell me one way
one guaranteed way you can
get into this location
i mean i didn't even try to get in here
they just you know told me where to go
and i went
so you know i just told you i see just
tell me where to go a hostage
i come here
i've got a stowaway
we have a hostage here i'm used to it
yeah i see okay he's used to it i'm used
to it okay
oh there's our laptop all right
with jake running low on battery uh oh
this game is being
paused
pause the game
plug it in all right
to ask the next
question
the quarter cast home of the best
accents
the best impressions
by sram by sean sharms accents
impressions by sam
hello and welcome to episode 118
impressions by sham
today i'll be making impressions
today of imaginary people
today i'll be making impressions of
imaginary people
and some real people let me introduce
you to chester he's a little figment of
my imagination i've carried with me
since i've been a boy
chester
he doesn't like it when you pronounce
the e and the r you see you have to
pronounce it chester
chester loves fast cars
jesse loves fast cars women and money
and money
[Laughter]
so jake
take it away whenever you want
[Laughter]
i just want to go out with the chester
impressions for a little bit
[Laughter]
you squiggly to jessa he's at it again
that's so good all right nick let's go
jake would you say that in order to have
a good time here
you have to
pay
or is this somewhere where all are
welcome you have to what
in order to have a good time here you
know enjoy yourself do you have to pay
extra for that or is it just you know
can anyone hang out
well
in order for me to have a good time i
first things i do is go and find my
friend chester when i'm done with that
the answer to your question frankly is
it it
it always
requires me to pay but what the the way
that i pay is in fact quite different
than everyone else here
[Music]
so that's my answer thank you you're
welcome
okay
wow
[Laughter]
have you only been asked one question
i haven't been asked anything you
haven't been asked the question yet
she has a whole voice jake she has a
whole nother she's got a whole gag for
this yeah
all right
jodin um
if i asked you to
move my car
would you say that would be
easy to do
for you
i would say it'd be quite impossible
quite impossible indeed
yes
yes
yes oh
yes would you prefer to stay
indoors or outdoors at this location
oh
why
for certain indoors at this location was
that certainly indoors the most i mean
some
some circumstances
want to be outdoors
but for me in very very specific
circumstances various very specific
circumstances
okay
all right well appears
chester has
identified a spy in our mist
to my right nicholas
that rascal because i want to be indoors
i would
say you
defend your honor oh are you trying are
you accusing me i'm curious this is the
official accusation you're on the stand
you're making official accusations
against my mind here
yeah you accuse me a famous musician on
my private jet
of being a spy
are you the spy sam
wait a minute wait a minute
did you just
did you win the game
no you accused me
you told me no you told me the location
but you just accused me
but now god damn it chester knows the
location i'll be playing it i don't know
how it works
are we doing this you can't give up the
location i thought i was just accused of
being a spy yeah yeah
yeah he told me
the location
yacht or the private jet oh am i not
supposed to do that
yeah it's okay
i thought like sometimes accusations are
made
like they accuse and then it's over no
no
it's simply a matter of defense systems
if you are the spy then you know then
there's one less person on the island
well then we all lose but it's okay
it's okay cause jay got it oh okay i i
thought it was the yacht actually
um i had it down to the yacht or the jet
let's try this one more time try one
more time it wasn't a very adult round
though let's let's get let's see yeah
like honestly kim kardashian's kids are
always on a private jet right yep
lots of kids go on private jets lots of
kids all right here we go this one's
gonna be
18 plus
let's see
this location is the meth lab
another spicy location
another adults
yeah why don't you kick it off
hey jake
all right
yep
yep
all right
lights up or lights down
around here
you know what i'm talking about
around here
lights up
[Laughter]
all right
all right
jordan
hi
hello hey um
can you uh
can you tell me what it is uh
you might see outside
at this location
[Music]
just take a look just take a little oh
take a look tell me what you see gravel
dirt
gravel
dirt
darkness
[Laughter]
all right
all right
yeah
great all right next up
nick yep
all right
don't worry i won't tell you that the
whole answer this time
do you want to live around here
boy
do you
you look at me when i'm talking to you
no
no
no
[Music]
that's your answers no
sam sam sam yes it all comes back to me
no one ever suspected him until he was
asked a question
nope
and then spend the night here do i want
to spend the night yeah like
do you want to spend the night here
you know some places you want to some
places you don't depends on your
character i guess yeah i mean
no
no this isn't no
it's not not not the place for you huh
not at least for me
um jake
no that figures
jordan
[Music]
chester spends the night here
fast cars in cash is chester's vibe
does this grow i mean does this place
no this is this up to his standards
is that your question yeah
is fast cars and cashmere that's a great
question
yes jordan please answer that are you
gonna see chester's car parked
you're gonna see chester here
would i see chester's car parked
maybe speeding
[Laughter]
that chester's a real animal you know
oh man he's a real animal
all right
all right all right all right the
thumbnails are gonna be chester ask away
jordan let's go
jake if you get frustrated here
how would you
what would you do how would you act on
it
well you're frustrated all right you
want to know that you want to know the
truth
yeah there was this one time
there was this one time
um
and i don't want to give away the
location because i feel like we've
already
gave up a lot
but
tragic
there is this one time where
well
a man can become so frustrated in this
place that uh
he might never come back
okay okay
all right
hate to be there when that happened i
hate to be there yeah he wouldn't come
back i'm not coming back
i'm just
where'd it go
g
g u n n g u h and gone
gun
all right
it's funny cool
all right
nick you're the you're my prime you're
my prime suspect right yeah he's mine in
the spotlight
um
given that we know that given that we
know that chester
speeds
right on by
as is public knowledge yes this is
publicly stated and known
um
i read the tabloids jake
would a man like
dog the bounty hunter
maybe
swing in
i mean
look if you're asking me whether you
would see dog the bounty hunter here
maybe on occasion but i mean he's a
human like everyone else you know
i'd say i'd say he probably has swung
there before
he's swung past tense there yes yes
on business perhaps
business
yeah
that's where i'm at
yeah
righteous brother
hey sam
blue
red
or brown
which one strikes a chord with you
brown
oh
interesting okay
um
i know i i
i'd like to put up i'd like to put it up
to a vote because i think the spy's on
to us
can i would you would y'all be okay with
that if i propose a name yeah yeah let's
hear it
i think it's nick
and i think he's on to us and i think we
need to vote
before you're going to be so
regretful if you do this because i know
who the actual spy is
it is
is it sham we all voted
for voting
i'm voting for nick
i'm not the spy
it's sick
i know
well
you kind of gave it away a little bit
i'm sorry i know but i knew you knew
dogs
bounty hunter
would be going past that meth lamb
god damn it you almost ruined it
you almost made me think it was the
swinger speech because you guys were
loose with
[Laughter]
i was trying to play it i was trying to
put an officer
you said there's lots of dirt and gravel
here and i was like and then i was
thinking about the chester thing it
would chester
we parked his car in the hell i was like
wow this is funny
um but i was trying to pass it off as
hell because i thought whoever the spy
was was on to us
uh and so when sam says
what made you think it was
yeah i thought it was you the whole
entire oh really yeah i thought it was
youtube the whole time too and then at
the end you started getting more
specific and i was like crap excellent
blue i was like
well i was trying to nail it down like
when you answered brown to that
i was just like okay it's sam but then
someone had a vote on me but he thought
it was hard
well can't meth can't meth be like brown
though i don't know it has it has shades
in pop culture
i think it can be like light shades of
brown if it's really impure how the heck
do they get to blue
well that was the thing walter white was
so dang good at it he made it blue i
guess or something i don't know
can can can you can christian play as
chester
chester springs
none other than
imaginary british sports car loving cash
enthusiast
he's just so unapologetically british
and people love him for it people love
it
[Laughter]
i think i smell
the beginnings of a great friendship
yes
in the beginning he's like
imaginary different
he's like real life james bond man
all right
it will quiet their stomachs that's what
this will require yeah yeah many hours
it will soften their many sam i hope
your children feel better and i hope you
enjoyed listener this game of spy fall
um if you'd like to see us play uh
scrabble let us know in the comments
below
um and if you'd like to see us uh
elaborate more on chester we can
certainly do that
thanks for listening and thanks for
watching and
you all have a great day